[Musica]
sono una migrante si una migrante anche
se sono nata in italia e non vi dico
dove sono nata dove vivo dove ho vissuto
ma ricordo benissimo il mio primo
viaggio migratorio a tre anni era una
bambina su quel treno con i miei
genitori che mi portava in germania non
avrei mai immaginato che quel primo
viaggio il primo di una lunga serie ebbe
in segnato così tanto e ora veniamo a
noi a questo viaggio
cosa ci vogliamo portare a casa stasera
da questo viaggio
qual è la cosa che volete portare con
voi che volete che vi rimanga dentro
scommettiamo che usciamo da questo ted
tutti un po più leggeri per diventare
leggeri dobbiamo fare delle cose insieme
incominciamo vi chiedo innanzitutto qual
è il vostro sogno
parlo ai vostri cuori quand'è l'ultima
volta che vi siete fatti definire dal
vostro sogno e non dal luogo dove siete
nati e allora per espanderci dobbiamo
svincolarci dalla logica del luogo
l'uomo è arrivato sulla luna
eppure
oggi indaga su nuovi pianeti in italia
ancora qualcuno ti chiede da dove vieni
in alcuni ambienti ancora ti appartiene
dobbiamo svincolarci dalla logica delle
classi se sei il figlio di un operaio
non è detto che tu debba fare l'operaio
si stai facendo l'operaio non è detto
che tu per sempre debba fare l'operaio
introd in questo paese la logica del
talento la logica del merito la logica
dello studio dell'artwork dicono gli
americani per espanderci poi ancora
dobbiamo svincolarci da un'antica logica
del potere accentrato nelle mani di
pochi
le nuove piattaforme tecnologiche ci
consentono di partecipare alle decisioni
nella nostra città consentono ai
cittadini di collaborare consentono la
nascita di nuove relazioni per to peer
nella gestione delle risorse pubbliche
nella gestione delle cose pubbliche una
gestione condivisa delle informazioni e
del potere
insomma una nuova logica politica ancora
in italia
incontriamo tanti burocrati tanti
potenti quasi medievali che ci dicono
lei non sa chi sono io e basta
svincoliamo ci da questa logica e
svincoliamo c anche dalla logica
dell'età guardate cosa sta facendo lei
greta tombe giovanissimi
ci sono nove leadership che avanzano
greta è riuscita a lanciare un
importante messaggio globale
sull'emergenza ambientale
a parlare ai potenti del mondo così
piccola così giovane in questi mesi
abbiamo visto le nuove leadership
emergere i nuovi governi guidati da
donne
[Musica]
e allora tutto può succedere anche da
giovanissime donne svincoliamo c inoltre
da altre barriere le barriere culturali
le barriere religiose
grazie alle nuove tecnologie oggi e
questa è una lezione che ho preso da
poco nell'ultimo viaggio che ho fatto a
israele andando a incontrare un mio ex
collega del programma di stato ivy alpi
a gerusalemme
lui guida una fondazione per lo sviluppo
delle imprese femminili nel rispetto
delle differenze culturali e religiose
di tutti di tutte le donne che
partecipano a questo progetto grazie
alle nuove tecnologie
una donna musulmana può collaborare con
altri uomini che vivono in altri
contesti
una donna del gruppo ultrareligioso può
collaborare con altri uomini che vivono
in altri contesti e addirittura alcune
donne da casa possono creare la loro
impresa
questo è quello che sta succedendo
proprio attraverso internet la rete e le
nuove tecnologie
l'innovazione sociale ed infine
svincoliamo c dalla logica di genere che
vede le donne relegate a posizioni di
minoranza nei governi nei consigli di
amministrazione nelle aziende nei board
delle aziende possiamo cambiare
mentalità in questo momento è in corso
una grande rivoluzione femminile
pensiamo al grande e profondo messaggio
di rula durante il festival di sanremo
che ci ha ricordato il nostro antico
profondo potere ma pensiamo anche a
fabiola gianotti la nostra italiana
direttrice del cern di ginevra
un orgoglio per tutti noi e pensiamo a
lei
alexandria ocasio cortez addirittura la
più influente nella gestione dei fondi
per la campagna elettorale ea lei
christine lagarde alla guida della bce
la senatrice warren oggi possibile
candidata per gli stati uniti senatrice
degli stati uniti per il massachusetts
insomma nel mondo qualcosa di profondo
sta avvenendo
eppure in italia vedo ancora tante donne
che soffrono tante donne in silenzio
anche in questa sala vedo tante donne
tante donne meravigliose e allora donne
liberate le vostre energie
fatevi avanti ribaltate i tavoli
chiedete il vostro spazio è in atto una
vera e propria rivoluzione rivoluzione
del sud rivoluzione femminile
rivoluzione del talento rivoluzione
ambientale rivoluzione giorni giovani e
generazionale è in atto una software
evolution
questo è il titolo del libro che scrissi
nel 2016 e che presentai un po in tutta
italia
[Musica]
una rivoluzione gentile diffidate da chi
vi propone una rivoluzione violenta una
rivoluzione drastica non finiscono mai
e in corso una grande e profonda
rivoluzione e noi ne siamo protagonisti
software evolution
[Musica]
[Applauso]